[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec alexei mais
ce kof ambassadeur de la fédération de
russie en france bonjour monsieur
l'ambassadeur
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france et de nous
recevoir dans cette très belle résidence
à paris vous êtes ambassadeur en france
depuis trois ans vous l'avez été en
italie puis nommé deux fois vice
ministre des affaires étrangères à
moscou sous la présidence de vladimir
poutine
on va parler bien sûr de politique
étrangère des relations avec la france
avec l'europe avec les états unis
l'afrique bien sûr sans oublier la
sphère de l'opposant russe alexeï
navalni et puis aussi du récent conflit
dans le haut karabakh et du processus de
paix avec l'ukraine justement un an
après la tenue du sommet au format
normandie à paris c'était le 9 décembre
dernier qui implique au plus haut niveau
la russie l'ukraine la france et
l'allemagne dans le règlement de ce
conflit
où en est le processus de paix il ya
d'eau moins cette date
je pense que cette date nous fournit une
occasion de réfléchir à l'ensemble du
processus qui se déroule en ukraine dans
le langage diplomatique
il existe la notion de capacité à
trouver un accord
campagne est de l'espace au buste au
cours des 20 dernières années le pouvoir
ukrainien à élaborer une doctrine
politique étrangère absolument nouvelle
sa sono nous puisque signe tous les
accords que tu veux rien ne t'oblige à
les appliquer cela s'applique à
merveille au résultat de cette rencontre
au format normandie tenue à paris il y
un an
[Musique]
dominés un peu je pense que je ne peux
pas vous faire de révélations
la russie a refusé de participer à cette
rencontre tant qu un communiqué
approprié n'aurait pas été élaborés et
signés
quant à la rencontre proprement dite
elle devait être principalement
consacrée à l'avenir du processus
destiné à rétablir la paix en ukraine
avant tout dans ces deux républiques non
reconnus mur nous croyez nous
winnipeg une hélice public zeleny
beaupré la déclaration a été signée
la rencontre a été fixée mais la
première chose qui a dit le président
ukrainien une fois arrivé à paris c'est
que ça n'allait pas et qu'il fallait
reprendre tous les accords depuis le
début je vais être franc cela fait
longtemps que je travaille dans la
diplomatie et les cas où les chefs
d'état négocié un communiqué en personne
pendant de longues heures sont rares et
cet axe ont été validés des axes
destinée à soutenir la mise en oeuvre
des accords de minsk une plymouth est
s'est inscrite de goadv s'est écoulé la
clause sur les changes de prisonniers a
en partie été respectée cela s'est
produit deux fois depuis
tout en sachant que la partie
ukrainienne n'a pas respecté
l'engagement principal à ce sujet autant
de points
l'annulation des poursuites pénales
contre les personnes de retour dans le
donbass
en fait ces personnes peuvent se
retrouver en prison à tout moment dès
qu'elles quitteront ces deux régions
factice qui est éludée mon but
le bluesman pas qui nous fait voir les
guillaume après trois autres turbines et
deuxième point même si la cessation des
hostilités aurait dû commencer en
décembre de l'année dernière elle n'a
commencé qu'elle était de cette année
elle est à peu près respectées tous les
autres points liés aux questions
politiques et économiques sont restés
lettre morte
où est mon beau souvenir pour nous mener
jusqu'au bout
est ce qu'il ya de plus inquiétant je
vous retranscris os c'est que les
autorités ukrainiennes déclare à
différents niveaux que l'ensemble des
mesures de minsk ainsi que la façon dont
elles sont formulées ne les satisfont
pas ces déclarations passe complètement
sous silence le fait que l'ensemble de
mesures en question a été entérinée par
une résolution du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu et représente à ce titre une loi
internationale
il ya eu des suspensions des discussions
lors de la dernière réunion du groupe de
contact qui je le rappelle rassemble
l'ukraine la russie et l'eau et c'est
eux le 25 novembre dernier pourquoi
cette rupture de discussions non d'après
ce que j'ai compris
rien n'est définitivement interrompue
mais la partie ukrainienne fait par
moments des crises d'hystérie
cette fois ils ont présenté l'ensemble
des mesures de minsk réécrit à leur
sauce
et ont refusé de prendre en
considération et les contre propositions
de lougansk et de donetsk comptent
quatre longueurs par un coup du destin
j'étais chargé des rapports avec le ca
au sein du ministère russe des affaires
étrangères
et j'ai donc participé à l'élaboration
de l'ensemble des mesures de minsk de sa
philosophie et de la configuration du
format du groupe de minsk
il y avait deux éléments principaux a
dit un élément
le premier élément était une série de
démarches la dernière étant le transfert
à l'ukraine du contrôle des frontières
entre ces deux républiques non reconnu
et la russie oublie comme il a si nous
sommes parfaitement conscients que si
nous avions commencé par là on aurait pu
oublier toutes les autres
c'était une décision politique mûrement
réfléchie que la partie ukrainienne a
accepté le second élément est il est
capital c'est que la rencontre de minsk
conformément au plan initial doivent
être des rencontres entre l'ukraine et
les représentants de lougansk et de
donetsk l'océan et la russie ne sont que
des médiateurs
aujourd'hui la partie ukrainienne
cherche à renoncer à cela aussi
moscou a récemment appelé les
partenaires français a adopté une
approche plus responsable dans leur rôle
de co médiateur pourquoi on devrait pas
une attitude nous avons toujours estimé
que le rôle des médiateurs était crucial
il a et médiateurs doivent maintenir une
distance égale avec les deux parties et
être objectif ça c'est la base
c'est le lait n'est pas seul et de me
rouler mais gugelmann faudra
malheureusement dernièrement le duo de
médiateur franco allemand a de plus en
plus tendance à soutenir de façon
inconditionnelle
la position de kiev coubisou pâte vierge
coligny qui au cours des mois d'automne
le ministre sergueï lavrov a envoyé à
son homologue français le ministre jean
yves le drian ifop suivre pas soigné
plusieurs messages détaillé contenant
énormément de fait face au sco collègues
ministres mais nous n'avons rien entendu
de concret en réponse au bout comme cris
vodka des ong dit que l'ukraine avait
élaboré cette nouvelle doctrine nombreux
signes tous les accords que tu veux car
rien ne t'oblige à les appliquer bien
entendu si nos homologues occidentaux
insistaient pour que l'ukraine respecte
ses engagements cette doctrine
n'existerait pas nous entendons souvent
à différents niveaux y compris moi lors
de diverses rencontres que la russie
doit faire ceci faire cela et je me
souviens de la rencontre de paris 5ème
ou 6ème heures l'un de nos homologues
occidentaux m'a dit en marge de la
rencontre
l'alexa d'escazeaux c'est sûr que vous
avez une position très confortable car
la russie n'est pas responsable d'aucun
point des accords de minsk
c'est vrai
la russie n'y est pas mentionné une
seule fois alors qu'en public
on nous accuse toujours de quelque chose
il y à peine quelques jours le
représentant permanent de la russie à
l'onu a émis des doutes sur l'utilité de
ce format normandie sur la tenue de
nouveaux forme de nouveaux sommets
suite à cette conduite de paris et
berlin que vous dénoncez est ce que vous
êtes optimiste néanmoins quant à l'issue
de ce processus de paix on assiste à
quelques phrases nous avons un proverbe
qui dit l'espoir meurt en dernier
mais étant donné que je suis impliquée
dans ce processus depuis 2014
je ne ressens aucun optimisme parce que
je ne vois pas chez les ukrainiens
je vois la capacité la volonté de
travailler avec leur propre république
pour arriver à des choses extrêmement
simple seul un prestige
de quoi parle-t-on en fin de compte la
bête doit y être restaurée et tyloo des
ces gens refusent de vivre avec des
partisans de bandeira qui font la
propagande du fascisme et du nazisme du
fascisme et nazisme pas être par
conséquent ils veulent avoir un certain
degré d'indépendance pour résoudre leurs
problèmes dans le cadre d'un état commun
optio goudenhooft a nié ils ne veulent
pas être qualifiées de criminelles
nous les plus soutenus comme les accords
de minsk prévoit noir sur blanc une
amnistie générale mais que distille en
ukraine
d'accord une amnistie générale mais
chaque personne ira au tribunal
et c'est le tribunal qui décidera si
elle fera l'objet d'une amnistie ou pas
but amnistie ligne et il ya encore deux
éléments tout simple ces gens par le
russe
ils veulent continuer à parler russe
l'ukraine veut le leur interdire et
enfin si les autorités ukrainiennes
veulent vivre avec ces personnes au sein
d'un même espace
c'est un axiome de base il faut
commencer par la coopération économique
il faut la relancer mais ils ne le
feront pas non plus à l'âge des états
unis des os
le président russe vladimir poutine a
récemment prolongé d'un an l'embargo sur
les produits alimentaires occidentaux
qui a été introduit en 2014 en
représailles aux sanctions décrétées par
les américains et les européens contre
moscou pour son rôle dans la crise
ukrainienne est-ce que vous avez bon
espoir que ces sanctions prennent fin à
un jour nouveau procès quant aux
sanctions
cette question ne nous est pas destiné
il faut l'adresser à bruxelles et à
washington
ce n'est pas nous qui les avons imposé
et ce n'est pas à nous de les annuler
ces sanctions d'ailleurs pendant la
seule présidence de trump les américains
ont imposé divers types de sanctions
contre la russie 1 47 ou 48 reprises une
autre série de sanctions est en
gestation
le parlement européen vient d'adopter
des sanctions
ils se sont tout à coup souvenu de la
liste mcg dit ce qui est ils ont de
nouveau adopté une série de sanctions
contre la russie il y a trois points
fondamentaux ici premièrement bien sûr
nous y avons toujours répondu et nous
continuerons d'y répondre de manière
réciproque mais pas au détriment de nos
intérêts économiques et grâce aux
sanctions la russie est devenue de facto
le premier exportateur de blé au monde
avant nous n'accordions pas beaucoup
d'attention à l'agriculture
bien que nous ayons toujours affirmé que
nous devions créer notre propre économie
puissante
c'est ce que nous faisons ces dernières
années bien sûr nous ne voulons pas nous
isoler du reste du monde
mais comme on dit le monde ne se limite
pas aux états unis et à l'europe y est
chaud il existe un grand nombre d'autres
pays en asie et en amérique latine
il y à cette structure
les brics brésil russie chine inde et
afrique du sud
ces pays représentent près de la moitié
de la population mondiale la moitié de
l'économie mondiale nous ne manquons
donc pas de partenaire pour travailler
mais je suis ambassadeur dans un pays
européen
et naturellement je souhaiterais
développer les liens économiques entre
la russie et la france
est ce que ces sanctions entravent le
développement de ces relations
oui mais nous trouvons malgré tout des
solutions conjointes dans la mesure du
possible
est-ce que la crimée selon vous restera
un point elle fait pas partie évidemment
des de ce format normandie denis des
accords de minsk est-ce que ça restera
dix romans un point de tension selon
voies entre l'ukraine et la russie et
entre l'europe et la russie et bien la
crimée si la russie j'ai regardé hier
l'une des dernières interviews du
président giscard d'estaing dans
laquelle il a donné son opinion sur la
crimée on y moscou et à parler au public
français au sujet de la crimée au
moyen-âge l'empiré ottoman voulait
prendre possession de ce territoire
il avait des relations particulières
avec la crimée puis la crimée
devient une partie de l' empire russe et
au cours de la guerre de crimée les
français combattait les russes et non
pas les ukrainiens et des os et staline
qui a organisé la conférence de yalta en
crimée avec roosevelt et churchill pas
le premier secrétaire du parti
communiste d'ukraine
donc en fait la crimée n'a jamais fait
partie de l'ukraine
et ce n'est pas ma vision personnelle
assez celle des habitants de la crimée
qui ont voté à plus de 90% et à deux
reprises en 1991 et tout récemment pour
leur attachement à la russie c'est leur
droit souverain et ils l'ont exercé
sacerdoce nasa fraîche dénigrer c'est
pour nous la question de la crimée est
close c'est l'une des entités de la
fédération de russie où il y en a même
deux la crimée et sébastopol
ce sont deux entités de la fédération de
russie extasier sur agent a coulé même à
propos il ya aussi un autre élément
intéressant est à goutte à goutte
cette année c'est l'anniversaire de ce
que l'on appelle l' exode liée à la fin
de la guerre civile en russie
c'était un exode des officiers de
l'armée blanche et de ceux qui n'ont pas
accepté le pouvoir soviétique
ce crime cet exode a eu lieu en crimée
et c'était le dernier endroit de la
russie qu'ils ont vu en quittant leur
pays dès l'époque qui nous fait rire
est ce qu'il ya un risque selon vous que
le cren relance le conflit armé à
l'instar de ce qu'a fait l'azerbaïdjan
dans le haut-karabagh effectivement les
autorités ukrainiennes sont
imprévisibles
mais elle mène une guerre avant tout
verbal il affirmait qu'il prendrait
bientôt moscou si je ne m'abuse ayant
verraient leurs armes et si unique
non mais j'ai du mal à imaginer qu'ils
oseraient s'engager dans une aventure
pareille
quoi qu'il en soit une telle menace
existe bien sûr que parce que ce sont
les autorités de kiev qui ont attaqué
donetsk est lougansk il mais ce n'était
en aucun cas une attaque de la part de
ces deux républiques non pas digne et
debout
on peut donc toujours s'attendre à
différents scénarios de la part de
l'agresseur j'espère donc en travaillant
dans le cadre du format normandie la
russie la france et l'allemagne
empêcheront une telle évolution des
événements
donc c'est a été cédé à ce propos le
président zelensky s'est proclamé
président de la paix tout comme son
prédécesseur qui avait déclaré la guerre
le 10 décembre dernier on va parler du
haut karabagh à présent la haye la
russie l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan ont
annoncé avoir signé un accord pour
mettre fin au conflit armé dans cette
région
il consacre des gangs territoire
important pour pour l'azerbaïdjan est ce
que cet accord était le seul possible
pour régler ce conflit selon vous c'est
un homme que c'était la seule solution
possible pour mettre fin aux hostilités
c'est pour cette raison que la russie a
tellement insisté là dessus pour que la
guerre cesse à ce territoire est
aujourd'hui nous savons qu'il y a des
milliers de victimes des deux côtés
stallone il est l'un des objectifs
principaux pour les jours à venir
l organisation d'un échange de personnes
détenues et l'europe à trimant décor
c'est l'un des appels de la déclaration
conjointe faite hier par les
coprésidents du groupe de minsk minsk au
niveau des ministres des affaires
étrangères il s'agit du ministre sergueï
lavrov du ministre jean yves le drian et
du secrétaire d'état américain
cet accord ne mentionne pas justement ce
groupe de minsk dont la france et est
coprésidente avec les états unis ce
groupe selon vous at il encore du sens
the howling la déclaration du 9 novembre
avec tous ces arrangements concerne
surtout le cessez le feu
par ailleurs certains éléments élaboré
dans le cadre du groupe de minsk
au cours de ces dernières années ont été
utilisés peuvent ainsi à sudbury cela il
décrit de manière explicite dans la
déclaration que j'ai mentionné n'en
sommes qu'au début du chemin
c'est un processus long et complexe nous
attend désormais urgent des process cela
inclut leur règlement politique
le rétablissement des liens économiques
et humanitaires ainsi que le retour des
réfugiés des deux côtés
la liste des choses à accomplir est
assez longue je suis persuadé que de ce
point de vue le groupe de minsk est très
loin d'avoir accompli sa mission et
qu'il sera encore nécessaire à l'avenir
ma question était posée parce que la
légitimité du groupe de minsk reposer
justement sur son rôle clé dans la
définition du statut du haut karabagh or
l'azerbaïdjan a dit que ce statut du
haut karabagh n'était plus sur la table
l'espagne vous savez tout chemin à un
point d'arrivée
bien sûr la décision politique final
durable puisque je n y appose ligne et
la définition du statut du haut karabakh
en résultant figureront parmi les
principaux éléments
il est évident que les parties au
conflit elle même
l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan auront une
grande responsabilité à assumer
il faut néanmoins commencer par quelque
chose
nous considérons que cela stabilisera la
situation c'est pour cette raison qu'ils
aient un contingent russe de soldats de
la paix est déployée dans la région
ensuite il faudra résoudre les questions
que j'ai mentionné les questions
auxquelles nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui
est ce que la france a un rôle à jouer
en parlant de la déclaration j'ai
mentionné le coprésident du groupe de
minsk la russie la france et les etats
unis 25 novembre le sénat français a
voté une résolution pour reconnaître
l'indépendance du haut-karabakh
c'est une résolution qui consacre de
fait le droit à l'autodétermination des
peuples est ce que ce serait l'une des
solutions selon vous je ne suis pas prêt
a commenté les décisions du sénat
français où sillonnaient je suis les
déclarations officielles de la russie
vous l'avez dire la russie a déployé
2000 soldats dans le haut karabakh pour
sur la ligne de front pour faire
respecter ce cessez le feu est ce que
pour vous c'est une solution durable est
là elle va y rester peut-être cinq ans
peut être plus quelle serait la solution
interne la plus la plus appropriée
nous ne partons pas des hypothèses
du poète et demi le présent accord est
conclu pour une durée de cinq ans il est
évident que c'est le contingent russe
qui satisfait le plus chacune des
parties
bîmes stoneham nous souhaiterions qu une
paix définitive s'installe le plus vite
possible et que nos militaires
reviennent à la maison
l'accord de paix ne mentionne pas non
plus la turquie qui revendique pourtant
un rôle dans le rétablissement et le
respect de ce cessez le feu sur place
elle a obtenu la création d'un centre
turc aux russes d'observation du cessez
le feu
ça pose encore quelques problèmes entre
la russie et la turquie
tout se peut même choisir la turquie est
un partenaire important de la russie sur
la scène internationale comme régional
que kof kof il ne s'agit pas uniquement
du caucase mais également d'autres
régions de la méditerranée
diao puis diot le dialogue se poursuit
et compris à ce sujet récemment les
ministres des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov et mevlüt cavusoglu se
sont entretenus ensuite il est prescrit
dans l'accord sur la création d'un
centre commun de surveillance que ledit
centre ne peut se situer sur les
territoires étant récemment passé sous
contrôle de l'azerbaïdjan des moyens
techniques de surveillance sont
mentionnés dans l'accord mais sur le
terrain il n'y aura que des soldats de
la paix russes
voici ce que notre camp et qui des
djihadistes syriens qui avaient été
envoyés à priori par ankara lent en
azerbaïdjan est ce que la question est
réglée
ce sujet sans mention directe des
terroristes syrien est traitée par la
déclaration des ministres du 3 novembre
valises teuf
la déclaration indique de manière
explicite à quel point est impératif le
départ de tous les mercenaires étrangers
de cette région
les gones on va parler de la france
depuis la visite de vladimir poutine le
29 mai 2010 est à versailles les
présidents français et russe se sont
rencontrés à plusieurs reprises le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
lui s'est rendu à moscou le 12 novembre
dernier pour demander une coopération
franco-russe renforcée en matière de
lutte contre le terrorisme et en matière
de lutte contre l'immigration
clandestine
comment selon vous peut cette
coopération peut elle être renforcée
il ya beaucoup de monde et je
n'emploierai pas le mot demandé on a
sept
car cette coopération se poursuit
the way i do avant même la visite du
ministre un groupe interministériel sur
les nouvelles menaces et défis s'étaient
réunis à paris et vous ce groupe s'est
surtout focalisée sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme
à mon avis le ministre a fait cette
visite à un moment propice et elle a été
utile notamment discutons et et vous
ouvre car les défis auxquels sont
confrontés la france la russie et le
monde entier demande une interaction
très net tombe y compris au niveau des
services secrets sauf dans le cadre du
nouveau dialogue avec la russie voulue
par emmanuel macron et initier justement
de on dit à l'été 2010 9 c'est jean yves
le drian qui est venu avec florence
parly ministre des armées à moscou dans
dans une rencontre au format 2 + 2 ce
qui était inédit depuis 2012
ce jour là le jean yves le drian a dit
le moment est venu le moment est propice
pour travailler à réduire la défiance
avec la russie plus d'un an et après
comment est-ce que vous qualifieriez les
relations avec la avec paris sont elles
bonnes bases et sur de la confiance sur
de la défiance ou en voie d'amélioration
mais n'allez bien vous avez mentionné la
rencontre à versailles
houston a eu une saute au cou mais au
cours de la dernière année
coque est apparue la notion d'esprit de
brégançon et il s'agissait bien sûr
d'une belle tentative des deux côtés et
à l'initiative du président macron de
rétablir les relations franco russes
voire de leur donner un nouveau départ
surtout dans le domaine de la sécurité
européenne
je ne peux pas dire que tout est réussi
et on a tout un ensemble de mécanismes a
été élaboré au cours des dix dernières
années
maintenant si nous voulons développer
les relations franco russes
il faudra remettre ces mécanismes en
marche il ya bobos
je ne serais pas honnête si je ne disais
pas qu'il ya une sorte de déception pour
la partie russe néanmoins cela ne veut
pas dire que nous ne sommes pas prêts à
travailler
nous sommes prêts à coopérer sur un pied
d'égalité
sur une base de confiance qui n'est pas
encore complètement rétabli alors il ya
eu il ya eu entre temps l affaire alexeï
navalni sept opposants russes qui
accusent la dîmière poutine de l'avoir
fait empoisonner accusations relayées
par la france et par l'allemagne
avez vous été amené à vous expliquer au
quai d'orsay où devant le président
macron à ce sujet notre coq de valeo
j'ai parlé de la nécessité de rétablir
la confiance que klaus indices les
actions de l'allemagne dans le cadre de
la sphère navalni soutenue par la france
pour des raisons incompréhensibles à nos
yeux et branle cette confiance devait
nous avons fourni à nos homologues
français du ministère des affaires
étrangères la totalité des informations
sur les données que nous avions
concernant cette affaire
blood spot mondiaux mais tu t'es les
bases à bruxelles nous avons fait quatre
propositions de coopération à
l'allemagne leur demandant les
informations qui étaient à leur
disposition si l'on est
nos services chargés d' analyse et de
tests sont très compétents ce n'est pas
un hasard si le spoutnik v le premier
vaccin contre le coc vide a été créé en
russie
si bolton
pouvez vous imaginer que la russie
envoie monsieur navalni en allemagne
sans faire toutes les analyses
nécessaires sans être sûr qu'il n'a pas
été empoisonné
nick acquis mais par des substances
militaire en russie est soudainement ma
vigne comme par un coup de baguette
magique ou plutôt tout droit sorti d'un
chapeau
on apprend par l'allemagne qu'il a été
empoisonné par une substance militaires
et autres ghosn a soigné comme bon en
occident on ne connaît pas d'autre nom
que le novice choc s'est dite et les
métiers feu mais nous avons tous été
témoins du spectacle de salisbury avec
des agents en tenue de cosmonaute
désinfectant la ville toute entière
alors que navalni pour revenir sur son
cas était dans un avion avec plus d'une
centaine de passagers à bord et personne
n'est tombé malade il séjournait dans un
hôtel où personne n'est tombé malade non
plus tout comme à l'hôpital où il a été
admis ensuite
on peut aussi remarquer qui lui a rendu
visite à la charité celle était en ce
moment chez nous comme en france il ya
malheureusement beaucoup de malades du
cog vide
il existe ce qu'on appelle des zones
rouges et moselle et nous savons quelles
mesures prennent des médecins pour se
protéger en rentrant en contact avec les
malades
monsieur navalni quant à lui se repose
et bénéficient d'un traitement en
allemagne aux frais de la partie
allemande
en même temps je ne sais pas si en
vérité les allemands paient pour cela je
les laisse s'exprimer là dessus mais
voilà ce que je veux dire comme la
france a également déclaré avoir trouvé
des traces
un type nos vies de choc
nous avons demandé des données à la
partie française comme hallelujah c'est
par ailleurs une mission de l'oif ac a
reçu une proposition de se rendre en
russie
jusqu'à présent elle n'a toujours pas su
faire ses valises
mais nous n'avons eu aucune réponse de
la partie française au dessus dans une
interview à fox news la chaîne de
télévision américaine il y a deux ans et
demi emmanuel macron a dit de vladimir
poutine je le cite il est fort et
intelligent mais ne soyons pas naïfs il
est obsédé par les interférences dans
nos démocraties
qu'en avez-vous pensé c'est assez
récurrents comme critique est nous y
sommes ni boudou je ne vais pas
commenter la déclaration d' emmanuel
macron macro n'est pas sot je suis un
ambassadeur accrédité en france non on
n'a pas collé il ya une petite histoire
anecdotique
une petite blague chez nous lorsqu'on a
posé une question sur la démocratie
staline a répondu avant je croyais que
la démocratie c'était le pouvoir du
peuple mais le président roosevelt m'a
bien expliqué que c'était le pouvoir du
peuple américain
c'est très drôle dans un entretien
publié en novembre par le magazine jeune
afrique emmanuel macron toujours à
dénoncer je cite la stratégie menée par
la russie et la turquie également pour
alimenter un sentiment anti français en
s'appuyant notamment sur un ressentiment
postcoloniale il avait déjà fait son
nommer clairement le président russe et
la russie à pau lors d'un sommet sur le
sahel
pourquoi ces critiques selon vous
et quelle est votre réaction à ces
accusations une fois de plus je ne suis
pas disposé à commenter les déclarations
d' emmanuel macron du plaignant gospel
macro et abu criteo je répondrai donc de
manière générale il ya ce dont je suis
diplomate de manière héréditaire en 1961
je suis arrivé en afrique avec mes
parents 2961 jusqu'à sa retraite
mon père qui est devenu ambassadeur à un
moment donné a travaillé en afrique et
l'union soviétique a été présente
partout en afrique
[Musique]
il est vrai que nos partenaires
occidentaux ont à de nombreuses reprises
essayé de chasser la russie d'afrique il
ya une série télévisée en ce moment on
en parle dans la presse de crâne il y à
un moment dans la série où la reine
britannique se rend au ghana pour
persuader le président nkrumah de ne pas
collaborer avec l'union soviétique
une fois de plus c'est le début des
années 1960 et je vous épargne les
banalités et ne vous rappelle pas par
exemple qui a construit le barrage
d'assouan en egypte
pourquoi dis-je tout cela n'est ni
bolchoï totalité legault deux périodes
gignac une petite période de 3 4 ans au
début des années 1990 durant laquelle la
russie n'a pas été très active en
afrique pour des raisons objectives
justice ne nous voit flou
et bien sûr maintenant nous sommes de
retour en afrique mais personne en
russie ne joue avec les sentiments des
peuples d'afrique n'évoque la
colonisation
ce taux des métaux colonise hotz monuc
tôt je n'y ait personne n'accuse
certains membres de l'établissement
africains d'avoir fait leurs études à
paris ou à londres
quel est alors le problème si une autre
grande partie d'entre eux ont fait leurs
études en russie ou encore en union
soviétique
[Musique]
je dirais même plus
nous avons une collaboration étroite et
efficace avec nos partenaires français y
compris dans la zone du sahel
cependant il faut dire que nos
homologues français n'aiment pas trop en
parler
quant aux histoires effrayantes la
presse ont fait circuler beaucoup quelle
quelle est la nature de la coopération
est ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
approfondir un peu cette coopération
dans le sahel avec la france justement
il y à des questions de sécurité
certaines branches de l'onu nous
collaborons au sein du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu pour adopter les
résolutions appropriées
alors il est vrai que la russie regagne
du terrain sur le continent africain
quitte à empiéter sur ce qu'on appelle
ici en france le pré carré français mais
vous avez des arguments la russie a des
arguments quels sont ils
mouais ce volume tout d'abord la russie
d'aujourd'hui n'accepte pas du tout la
dite doctrine brejnev dont nos
partenaires occidentaux se servent
beaucoup aujourd'hui
bien sûr dans certains pays on parle une
même langue et dans d'autres pays une
autre langue mais ce n'est pas une
raison pour considérer ces zones comme
son pré carré
je reviens au sujet de l'économie depuis
longtemps cela ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
les grandes sociétés russes sont sur le
continent africain
9 le 15 qui clignote non seulement dans
le but de développer les infrastructures
même si nous participons aussi à cela de
manière active
non mais également afin de mettre en
place des chaînes de production
d'entreprise campagne je vais vous
donner un exemple très simple et si pour
un fabricant russe d'aluminium qui
produit en europe
il est moins cher d'importer de la
bauxite de guinée que d'australie il y a
quand même plus de chances qu'ils
s'implantent en guinée tout non
comment l'économie est aussi un domaine
de concurrence non mais disons qu'à une
époque où les choses allaient mieux nous
avions des pourparlers avec la france
sur une coopération dans différents pays
d'afrique y compris dans le nord du
continent presse mais aussi la russie et
la france ne peuvent que bénéficier
d'une telle coopération plutôt que d'une
rivalité aveugle monsieur l'ambassadeur
on va parler de la crise sanitaire qui
intéresse évidemment au niveau mondial
comment la russie et l'europe
peuvent-elles coopérer dans la
résolution de cette crise sanitaire et
notamment sur la mise à disposition des
femmes au vaccin
je suis intimement persuadé que dans la
lutte contre le coronavirus il ne doit y
avoir ni de course économique ni encore
moins politique - gonzàlez leach tôt je
peux vous assurer que le vaccin scouts
nickelés spoutnik lui un homme n'a pas
été élaboré dans un but de propagande la
création du vaccin n'a pas non plus été
motivée par la volonté de le vendre sur
le marché européen avant toute autre
chose le spoutnik v a été créé afin de
vacciner la population russe et cette
semaine ou la semaine prochaine commence
la vaccination de masse avec ce vaccin
dans différentes régions de la russie
toutefois dans les conditions actuelles
il serait même en quelque sorte
criminelle de garder les choses pour soi
c'est pour cette raison que nous avons
proposé à tous les pays qui le
souhaitent
participer à la production du spoutnik
vais surtout pour vacciner c'est sa
propre population
nous sommes prêts à fournir toutes nos
connaissances technologiques
à ce titre ce tron parmi les pays de
l'union européenne c'est la hongrie qui
s'y intéresser ce n'est pas non plus un
grand secret que les spécialistes
français se sont également rendus à
moscou afin de prendre connaissance de
nous donner à ce sujet mais si on parle
de chiffres importants c'est l'inde qui
va produire d'immenses quantités de ce
vaccin
il n'est même pas besoin de citer
d'autres pays en ce moment nous avons
deux autres vaccins qui arrivent dont
l'un est destiné plutôt aux aînés mais
alors que dans presque chaque famille
donc on voit qu'ils ont mis les mains ou
sirleaf chaque famille à travers la
planète des gens qui ont été ou sont
malades du code vide aller en sont morts
ou religieuses mais je pense que le seul
moyen de combattre cette épidémie est
d'unir nos efforts on va parler de notre
chaîne arte france qui n'est toujours
pas accréditer auprès de l'elysée trois
ans après sa création alors que
j'imagine que la chaîne france 24 est
accrédité auprès du kremlin
est ce que les choses avancent sur ce
dossier c'est une question pour la
partie française bien sûr peuple un must
comme notre voie car je ne me souviens
pas d'une seule rencontre importante
entre dirigeants russes et français où
nous n'aurions pas évoqué la question de
rt france vous connaissez les problèmes
que rencontrent russie à tous day dans
d'autres pays on a peur d'entendre la
vérité je connais un homme d'affaires
important qui travaillent à
l'international business mais makoun il
m'a raconté comment il commence sa
journée
il regarde cnn bbc et russie a tous des
gars comme il l'a expliqué les deux
premières chaînes ne lui donne pas de
vision correcte de la situation dans le
monde alors qu'il doit faire face à des
problèmes économiques significatifs
non ce qui se passe nous étonne beaucoup
du côté russe tout ou presque
même à l'époque soviétique
les gens étaient agrippés à leur poste
de radio
la nuit pour trouver une fréquence
étrangères
cetto sur laquelle on pouvait écouter
les livres de soljenitsyne et maintenant
nous devons écouter spoutnik et vous
soutenir
ça n'a pas de sens dans tous les cas en
russie contrairement à la situation dans
les pays occidentaux
là dessus l'accès au champ de
l'information est ouvert à tout le monde
que nice n'y fait et où ce but pour
répondre à votre question il ne serait
pas du tout souhaitable d'introduire des
contres sanctions dans ce domaine le
boul
cependant des sujets encore plus
complexe apparaissent aujourd'hui tels
que le contrôle exercé par certains
organismes sur les grandes plateformes
informatiques qui censurent sévèrement
toute opinion alternative et cela dans
le domaine d'internet c'est affolant
un mot sur valéry giscard d'estaing
quels souvenirs garderez-vous de
l'ancien président de la république
française
outre les jusqu'à ce thème bien sûr la
perte de valéry giscard d'estaing est
une grande douleur pour nous tous j'ai
eu le privilège de faire sa connaissance
il y a une dizaine d'années le biais 7
lors de son discours à l'université
lomonossov de moscou
dans le cadre d'une visite en russie il
venait souvent réussi et je les ai
rencontrés à plusieurs reprises depuis
que je suis ici j'ai toujours été
marquée par la clarté de son esprit son
esprit visionnaire il était vraiment
préoccupé par la détérioration de la
situation en europe sur toi de vivre la
situation de cette nouvelle europe
la construction de laquelle il a
consacré une grande partie de sa vie
paul fréjus
son idée principale était qu'il ne
fallait pas installer de rideau de fer
entre nous et crocs de lock up se livrer
à des course aux armements mais qu'il
fallait revenir au processus politique
rétablir la confiance sont en ligne on
devait arriver à une détente du 21e
siècle en quelque sorte ce qui nous
concerne le coc vide nous a fait mal
deux fois cette année à ce que je sais
son décès est également due aux
coronavirus cette année nous avions
prévu d'importants événements pour
commémorer les 75 ans de la victoire
dans la seconde guerre mondiale
[Musique]
valéry giscard d'estaing était justement
censé occuper une place au premier rang
du gradin lors du défilé de la victoire
à moscou car il était alors le seul
président en vie à avoir participé à
cette guerre lui tout était prêt pour sa
visite mais nous avons dû renoncer aux
festivités à cause du coc vide
merci monsieur l'ambassadeur de nous
avoir accordé cet entretien merci à vous
de votre fidélité c'est la fin de la
grande interview rester avec nous sur rt
france
[Musique]